before that the government wants to
reform education for over 16s to better
equip them
for the world of work uh who better to
speak to them than the education
secretary gavin williamson
uh joining us once again on the program
mr williamson good to see you this
morning
um it does feel like this is the first
big move in
in boris johnson's lifetime skills
guarantee just tell us a bit about
it well this is
you're absolutely right it's a big move
it's about all about building back
better
it's about making sure there's every
youngster
or anyone of any age who's uh taking on
these qualifications
it's really focused around uh it's
really focused around getting them a job
at the end of the
end of their course it's all built about
it's about bringing
businesses into the center in terms of
deciding as to
what courses need to be done what are
the local needs of the
market place and the local uh the local
area it's very much
like the germans and the swiss do
and actually it goes to show that it
delivers results
um you know we've got some real big
skills gaps in some of these areas you
know whether it's a
cyber security whether it's construction
whether it's advanced manufacturing
and it's actually plugging those holes
and it's uh it's probably long overdue
but this is a really significant reform
bringing businesses into the sense
through everything it
isn't the case though that sixth foreign
college's um further education
establishments in general
already reach out to businesses working
in their community i mean isn't that
isn't the biggest problem
in essence with further education
colleges sick form colleges that
you know according to that ifs report
from last year they've seen the biggest
falls in education funding of any part
of the education sector
don't they just need more yeah so
you're right to say that uh you know
colleges
have uh often had good links but what
we're proposing to do is actually put
chambers of commerce business
organizations really at the heart in
terms of actually
uh designing the sort of skills mix for
the local area
this is something that's happened in
many other countries and worked really
well
um and it's something that we've needed
to do in this country for an awful
long time because actually only 20
percent of courses are taught in
colleges
uh are related directly into the world
of work
we want to change that and actually flip
it the other way around so it's 80
percent of courses
but you're right to say about more
funding going into colleges
uh that's why we're putting an extra one
and a half billion pounds in terms of
capital build over this parliament
we've got the two and a half billion
pound uh skills fund
and we've been seeing uh substantial
increases into
the money that's going into 16 to 19
education because
we're recognizing we really need to
power ahead in terms of the investment
in this sector
mr williamson can we talk covert 19 for
a second some pretty distressing
research emerging from from imperial
college london this morning that
suggests
cases might not contrary to the data
that the government has been putting
forward
the cases might not be falling across
england at the moment
what is your what is your sense of what
is going on here i mean
if that is correct it does rather feel
like we need to go back to the drawing
board in terms of whether or not
lockdown actually works
well obviously imperial college uh very
respected institution
the government always looks really
closely at all the evidence and all the
advice
that comes forward that's the right
approach to be taking
um and you know that's why we have sage
to look at a whole set of uh different
research
different advice i think everyone uh
right across the country not just in
government
wants to see brisbane exiting from
lockdown at the
earliest possible stage but we've had to
take these measures in order to
alleviate pressure on the nhs um
you know the the evidence that we've
been seeing is that actually
it has been having an impact in terms of
relieving some of that pressure on the
nhs so the nhs is able to cope but of
course
government always looks at all the
evidence that's available
well some some of the evidence that has
been analyzed by the national education
union
came from the government are we now at a
point where we can say actually you know
what
schools are are not safe i mean the
national education union saying
saying that you know if you're if you're
looking at comparing a covered infection
in schools versus in the general
population it's almost
two times higher amongst primary and
secondary teachers than in the general
population
if you look at teaching assistants and
other staff
it's three times higher in primary
schools seven
times higher in special schools can we
finally dispel the idea that
schools are safe schools are a safe
environment to be in
and if you look at the evidence dr jenny
harris was giving
to the education select committee just
earlier this week
really emphasizing the fact that
actually not only those children
who are in school still and remembering
that you know 20
of children are still going into school
because uh
either children critical workers or
vulnerable children
um um and they're safer for children
for those who are working in schools and
it doesn't look very safe for schools
though i'd say again it did the
infection rate amongst teachers and
secondary and primary is twice as high
as it is in the general population now
you can say
that it is safe in the sense that
children if they contract covered 19
are unlikely to get the most severe side
effects
so the severe effects of the of the
condition but clearly
for teachers it is less safe to be in a
school than it is to be out in the
general population
yeah well um what the evidence has been
is actually sort of teachers are no
more vulnerable than any other sort of
workforce and actually very much within
the national average so
um i'm i'm not sure where the nau are
getting the statistics from because it
looks as if they're not comparing like
we'd like what's so incredibly important
the measures that we put in place at the
start of a pandemic in terms of
welcoming children
into school in terms of first national
lockdown norway through
has always had the safety of children
and the workforce at the heart of it and
that's why you've seen
the fact that you know schools have
continued to be able to operate
including in
very high um you know in areas with very
high
uh levels of covid in a sort of safe and
sort of uh
you know proper way and you know it's
right that we put those measures in
place
but the statistics don't actually go to
point out that children
uh children or teachers are any more
vulnerable than you know any other sort
of workforce
so when will the schools be reopening or
at the very least
can you tell us when you will be telling
the schools
when they'll be reopening well what we
will be wanting to do is give schools as
much notice as possible so teachers can
get ready
children can prepare and parents know in
order to be able to manage their lives
and we would want to give
all schools uh a clear two weeks notice
period in order to be able to say
that that's themselves you'll be telling
them in a week's time then is that the
case you'll be telling them in a week
because that's
two weeks then basically until uh the
the other side of the easter
that's other side of the february yeah
we'd be wanting to give
uh you know people as much notice as
possible in order to prepare in order to
get ready in order to welcome children
back
now one of the key criterias as to
whether the pressure on the nhs has
started to lift that's why we had to
take
the national decision very much in the
national interest one
one that i personally never would have
wanted to take to see schools closed
again
we had to make that decision uh because
of the pressure on
the nhs and needing to reduce movement
in society
and in communities but schools were the
last to close
schools will very much be the first to
open
um on a pretty personal note you've come
in for a degree
of criticism this week the opposition
have called for your resignation
the reason they have done so is that we
have seen a succession
of u-turns from your department the very
latest of which
uh getting rid of the the plans to have
uh
daily testing in schools much trumpeted
by yourself but that's not the only one
u-turns on returning to primary school
once not twice in fact
free school meals face masks the exam
backlash that you and i talked about as
well
there is there is a real question about
your competence at minister
how would you respond to it given that
the litany
of u-turns that your department has
participated in
so we're dealing with a global pandemic
and actually if you go back a month if
you'd asked me did i expect to be in a
position where we see
all schools closed right across the
country i wouldn't have expected to be
doing that nor would anyone else uh but
we
saw the emergence minister the unions
were talking about
it as were you as what parents were
talking about it
sage was talking about it
this wasn't uh this wasn't something
that we wanted to see
we'd always said and we always have done
done everything we can do to protect
education make sure that schools stay
open
my focus has and always will be in
delivering the very best and you know
it's really interesting for politicians
and journalists to talk about their
future careers of politicians my real
focus as we're talking about today is
making sure that uh
you know children get back into school
at the earliest possible
opportunity my focus is making sure that
we're not just talking about the 50
of students that go off to university
but the other 50 percent they need to
have
you know the skills for the jobs that
they need for the future
that's what we're focusing on we want to
bring all schools back we
we want to bring all pupils back into
those schools at the earliest possible
moment
that's for focus but yes you know we
have had to make
uh swift decisions on many issues uh
decisions that sometimes we didn't
expect to
be having to make but uh you know that
is one of the
consequences of having to deal with a
global pandemic